what are we on like day 700 of the 15
days to slow the spread the fact of the
matter is i think we've learned you give
these people an inch they will never let
go they're going to take a mile they are
going to restrict they're going to
mandate they're going to lock you down
and we cannot accept that obviously in
florida we do not accept it so there's
no reason to be restricting or mandating
anybody
throughout our country
speaking of florida ben shapiro editor
emeritus of the daily wire moved from la
to florida during the pandemic and he
joins us i believe from florida right
now ben good morning to you good morning
good morning
so the senate has voted to block joe
biden's vaccine mandate for employers
you have been fighting the federal
government in court where are you at
this point
so basically we are still on hold with
the sixth circuit court of appeals uh
the government sort of pushed back
against a stay that had been put in by
the fifth circuit we put in a brief on
that so everything is sort of in a
holding pattern at this point in the
court system obviously there's a
national stay that's been put on the vax
mandate um but we assume that eventually
this case is going to reach the supreme
court and we've asked people to sign a
petition that we put out there called do
not comply petition.com already 850 000
americans have signed a petition saying
they're not planning on complying with
any sort of employer of acts mandate
pushed by this administration and but we
should point out and you've said this on
this program before you're not
anti-backs you've been vaccinated your
family's been vaccinated we've all been
vaccinated you're just anti-vax mandate
correct there's a massive difference
between being anti-vax and anti-vax
mandate despite the attempts to
literally redefine the term anti-vaxx in
the dictionary it just shows the
cultural dominance of the left being
anti-vax means that you actually think
that the vaccines are actively bad being
anti-vax mandate means that you believe
that people should be free to make their
own decisions particularly when the
scientific suggestion that the data show
that even vax people are passing this
that vaccination is preventing
hospitalization and death but not
transmission that vaccination is
preventing hospitalization and death but
it's not preventing people from from
getting the disease although in lower
numbers than people who are unvaxxed so
vax mandates are anti-logic they're
anti-science and they're not have
freedom but there are a lot of people
watching that are sick of this it's been
two years of the government telling us
and changing the rules over and over and
going back and forth uh if people want
to get involved they can sign your
petition right
that's right do not comply petition.com
to get involved and then you can move
down if you're in a blue state move to
florida
you heard our governor we'd all like to
you know it's interesting uh governor
polis of colorado said you know
the problem is yeah democrat said you
know the problem is unvaccinated in his
view but he's done state emergency is
over and here's the bad part we lost 27
air force personnel yesterday because
they refused to take the shot we lost 34
000 health care workers in new york
because they even have either have
natural immunity or they're not
comfortable
taking the shot now do you know that
anthony fauci says we got to get a
booster so that's three for a lot of us
and they said we might have to get it
annually that'll be four and now with
the omnichrome they're working on a
different shot how many shots are we
gonna get even the most pro vaccine
person is there a limit to the pin
cushion in your deltoid
no i think that until your body is 80
composed of the actual vaccine then
they're not going to allow you to be
free listen if you actually think at
this point that there is any point at
which the left is going to allow you to
live your life that if you just do one
more thing the left will allow you to
get back to normal that's just not true
they made a promise the promise was a
lie their promise was they would be able
to stop kovid no government anywhere on
earth has been able to stop covid the
only thing the government can do is make
the vaccines widely and universally
available they've already done that that
means now we all get to go back to daily
life and we here in florida we know that
because we've been living normal daily
life for well over a year at this point
that's right uh ben shapiro author of
great book called the authoritarian
movement ben we thank you very much also
check out his the ben shapiro show thank
you sir
yeah thanks so much i'm steve ducey i'm
brian kilmeade and i'm ainsley earhardt
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis